I got an interview with Roland Palmer
and it's on campus it's in Manhattan
we're always talking about going into
Manhattan for a special evening this is
gonna be absolutely fantastic later
maybe we could take a carriage ride yeah
if it doesn't rain you're by far the
most interesting American director since
this is your first meaningful assignment
would you like a scoop I can't make
lunch when is going through this Horatio
artistic crisis it's a scoop that's be
nice to see it's good to see you what
are you doing just out of here trying to
create a modern film noir classic okay
all right do you want to be in it hey
should we do this
hey are you gonna keep your mouth closed
have a girlfriend Shannon I don't think
I could do this c19 take two action
[Music]
Josh it's starting to rain you cut see
Eddie you could do it tell your
girlfriend Ashley what's going on you
said you're gonna call me 30 minutes ago
17 million dollar movie and Rowleys very
unhappy with it Nicole and Rowley
yeah and Ted and I we have to find him
before he has one of his crazy fits
whose head was that your boyfriend yeah
a little eccentric Rolly my god you're
Francisco Vega
he's that good or bad my roommate thinks
you're the greatest thing to come along
since the morning-after pill
Francisco Vega is in town with his new
main squeeze on his arm my girlfriend
dumped me a movie star are you doing
your own don't make dreams come true how
do you do that I get five hundred
sweetie how'd you like to make five
thousand mother this is my girlfriend
Ashley Enright better grow up and get a
profession you think a girl like that
wants to live hand-to-mouth funny you
should put it that way she's apparently
onto a very big story she takes her job
very seriously I shouldn't imbibe so
copiously I become passionate aggressive
absurd I just hey Ashley I can't talk to
you right now what could possibly be so
secretive about that unless there's some
funny business going on unless there's
some funny business going on
this is real life real life is fine for
people who can't do any better just make
one tiny little a lousy hour interview
instead look the whole weekend I'm on to
a real story here
take off your way into it I can't I have
no clothes underneath
[Music]
you